bitte jetzt bitte jetzt hin zu setzen
liebe kolleginnen kollegen ich begrüße
sie sicher bundespressekonferenz nach
der gestrigen video konferenz des
europäischen rates dazu bringt sich die
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel begrüßte
den bundesgesundheitsminister gern
sparen und den präsidenten des robert
koch institutes herrn villa sein die uns
alle herzlich willkommen die
bundeskanzlerin fängt an
wir haben einen klaren und herren wir
haben in der tat gestern abend oder am
späteren nachmittag eine video-konferenz
von den staats und regierungschefs
zusammen mit der präsidentin der
europäischen kommission ursula von der
leyen und dem ratsentscheid shell und
der präsidentin der europäischen
zentralbank christine lagarde und ich
möchte sie als wäre es ein europäischer
rat gewesen einfach auch über diese
konferenz informieren
das hat sich natürlich um die fragen um
den um das kona virus gedreht bei dieser
videokonferenz- und es war nebenbei
bemerkt die erste video konferenz der
staats und regierungschefs also man
sieht die digitalisierung und die neuen
formen der kommunikation ziehen überall
ein
wir haben entlang von vier themen
diskutiert das erste war das thema der
eindämmung der gefahr die von dem koma
virus ausgeht das virus ist in europa
angelangt es ist da das müssen wir alle
verstehen und die maßstäbe wie wir
darauf reagieren auf ein virus dessen
dass wir noch nicht ausreichend kennen
für dass wir keine therapie haben für
dass wir keinen impfstoff haben die
maßstäbe für unser handeln unser
politisches handeln ergeben sich aus dem
was uns wissenschaftler und experten
sagen deshalb ist es mir auch sehr
wichtig dass heute nicht mehr
bundesgesundheitsminister hier mit mir
sitzt sondern das institut das für diese
expertise steht zusammen mit vielen
ausgewiesenen fachleuten nämlich das
robert koch institut und designchef herr
professor wieder wenn wir sie wissen
dass der bundesgesundheitsminister sie
auch regelmäßig jetzt mit diesen
wissenschaftlern gemeinsam informiert
und sie werden an dem verlauf der
pressekonferenz und von woche zu woche
auch sehen dass sich der wissensstand
verändert und dass die einschätzungen
auch klarer werden aber eben auch neue
einschätzungen hinzu treten können
weiter muss man verstehen wenn das virus
da ist und noch keine immunität der
bevölkerung gegenüber diesem virus
vorliegt keine impfmöglichkeiten
existieren auch noch keine
therapiemöglichkeiten dass dann ein
hoher prozentsatz experten sagen 60 bis
70 prozent der bevölkerung infiziert
werden so lange dieser zustand so bleibt
und deshalb wird ja auch darauf komme
ich noch so intensiv an
therapiemöglichkeiten und impfstoffen
gearbeitet
das wiederum so ist und man weiß dass es
besondere gruppen in der bevölkerung
gibt nämlich ältere und menschen mit
vorerkrankungen die einen schwereren
verlauf dieser viruserkrankung haben
können dann bedeutet das dass dieses
vorgehen davon bestimmt sein muss dass
wir unser gesundheitssystem nicht
überlasten sondern mit den möglichkeiten
des gesundheitssystems so umgehen dass
wir die ausbreitung des virus und die im
feld der infizierung verlangsamt und
deshalb sind alle maßnahmen die wir
machen von allergrößter bedeutung weil
sie uns zeit geben es ist eben nicht
egal was wir tun es ist nicht vergeblich
ist es nicht umsonst auch wenn sich die
ratschläge verändern weil die ratschläge
wie man vorgehen soll
die empfehlungen orientieren sich immer
an der frage wie wir sicherstellen dass
unser gesundheitssystem nicht überlastet
wird in der zeit in der wir uns mit
diesem virus auseinandersetzen müssen
es geht also um das gewinnen von zeit
und wir werden dann natürlich auch
prioritäten setzen müssen
wichtig ist dass alle staatlichen ebenen
arbeiten können das gilt für die polizei
das geht über die bundeswehr das gilt
für die kritische infrastruktur das gilt
für politische entscheidungen dass die
medizinische möglichkeiten genutzt
werden können das medizinische personal
arbeiten kann ich will an der stelle
übrigens ein riesen dankeschön sagen an
viele die heute schon sehr sehr hart
belastet sind
und das geht dann darum dass wir das
wirtschaftliche leben einigermaßen
aufrechterhalten können und deshalb
kommt in der frage was können wir denn
dann zur verlangsamung beitragen
natürlich eine priorisierung und eine
nachrangigkeit und deshalb ist eben ich
nicht das zentrale problem auf ein
fußballspiel wenn ich das so hart sagen
darf mit oder ohne publikum stattfindet
wenn man dazu einen beitrag dazu leisten
kann dass menschen die krank sind
menschen die alt sind nicht in eine
situation kommen wo sie vielleicht nicht
mehr medizinisch die richtige behandlung
führen können dann ist das genau das
verhalten was wir jetzt brauchen und so
gibt es viele dinge deshalb gibt es
empfehlungen die dass der
bundesgesundheitsminister ausgesprochen
hat dass weniger als 1000 menschen
veranstaltung mit mehr als 1000
teilnehmern abgesagt werden sollten aber
man kann auch unterhalb dieser schwelle
etwas tun und damit einen guten beitrag
leisten
wir wissen dass ganz europa von diesem
virus erfasst ist also jedes europäische
land ist betroffen
zum teil in unterschiedlicher art und
weise das sagt die video konferenz
gestern ergeben und ich möchte etwas in
richtung unserer italienischen freunde
sagen die in europa zurzeit am
schwersten betroffen sind die berichte
von dort die aussagen auch von
medizinern und medizinischem personal
das am rande der überforderung arbeitet
bedrücken uns sehr und wir denken auch
mit
großer sympathie an die menschen auch an
die politisch verantwortlichen in
italien und wünschen ihnen von herzen
dass die harten maßnahmen wie sie jetzt
jahr für das land auch gewählt haben
dort eine wende zum besseren bringen
die video konferenz hat herausgebracht
dass wir uns eng abstimmen müssen das
sollen die gesundheitsminister machen
wie auf der minister ebene oder aber
staatssekretärsebene täglich miteinander
in kontakt sein sollten
die europäische kommission wird
renommierte theologen in einem
expertenkreis sozusagen zusammenstellen
um mit ihnen auch immer zu beraten wie
ein einheitliches möglich abgestimmtes
vorgehen in europa stattfinden kann
es geht jetzt nicht darum dass wir uns
in europa voneinander abschotten sondern
es geht darum dass wir einen modus
finden indem möglichst kein
gesundheitssystem in der europäischen
union überfordert wird das führt
natürlich auch zu der frage der
medizinischen ausstattung wir haben eine
ganze reihe von nachfragen weil wir eine
export erlaubnis für medizinische güter
eingeführt haben ich habe den
kolleginnen und kollegen im europäischen
rat erklärt das heißt nicht dass wir
nichts mehr exportieren
aber wir wollen wissen dass es in die
richtigen hände kommt und an die
richtigen stellen denn das ist jetzt von
entscheidender bedeutung und das ist
glaube ich auch so verstanden
wir müssen einen fokus richten auf die
forschung
ich habe dafür geworben dass wir gerade
der allianz die sich mit forschung
erforschung von mit impfstoffen befasst
dass wir diese unterstützen und alle
europäischen fähigkeiten und
möglichkeiten auch koordinieren und
deutschland hat ja selbst sehr schnell
da dankte auch dem haushaltsausschuss
des deutschen bundestages mittel zur
verfügung gestellt 140 millionen
um dieses im programm auch schnell
voranzubringen
der vierte punkt sind die
wirtschaftlichen folgen das alles was
jetzt passiert sie wissen was von hotels
von messe betreibern von gaststätten von
vielen anderen geht an die der
wirtschaft nicht spurlos
vorüber und deshalb geht es hier in
europa um ein koordiniertes vorgehen bei
dem jeder mitgliedstaat seinen beitrag
leisten muss und ich darf sagen dass die
bundesregierung hier sehr schnell
gehandelt hat sie haben gestern von der
einführung des kurzarbeitergeldes gehört
wie wir es auch in zeiten der finanz-
und bankenkrise hatten wir haben eine
gute soziale sicherungssysteme die als
automatische stabilisatoren wirken
wir haben das infektionsschutzgesetz das
erstattungen möglich macht im
zusammenhang mit solchen
infektionskrankheiten wir haben das
instrument der lohnfortzahlung was nicht
überall auf der welt existiert und wir
werden noch im rahmen dieser woche
liquiditätshilfen zur verfügung stellen
insbesondere über die kreditanstalt für
wiederaufbau
das heißt wir werden uns rüsten und auch
mit der wirtschaft den dialog suchen und
wir werden auf der europäischen ebene
den stabilitäts und wachstumspakt
flexibel handhaben das war gestern eine
wichtige schlussfolgerung wir werden die
beihilferegeln flexibel handhaben und es
wird eine sogenannte korona response
investment initiativ auf der
europäischen ebene in höhe von 25
milliarden investitionen geben
die deutsche situation ist
gekennzeichnet dadurch dass wir ein
föderales land sind das heißt es erlaubt
dezentrales und am problem angepasstes
handeln das ist ein vorteil dass ich
alles sozusagen an einer stelle
konzentriert ist und deshalb möchte ich
auch an die jetzt ja vor vollkommen neue
herausforderungen gestellten
gesundheitsämter landratsämter
oberbürgermeister ein herzliches
dankeschön formulieren
aber wir müssen natürlich auch sagen
föderalismus ist nicht dafür da dass man
verantwortung wegschieben sondern
föderalismus ist dafür da dass jeder an
seiner stelle verantwortung wahrnehmen
und wir werden morgen eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz haben wir
müssen abgestimmt miteinander handeln
auf allen staatlichen ebenen möglichst
auch gleich bei gleicher situation egal
in welchem bundesland sich die situation
ab spielt und ich glaube es wird nun
wirklich gut daran von der bundes
bis zur lokalen ebene dass wir den
empfehlungen die uns auch vom
robert-koch-institut gemacht werden nach
kommen und uns danach richten wir sind
also in einer sitzung situation in der
vieles noch nicht wissen
und das was wir wissen müssen wir sehr
ernst nehmen wir müssen alle kräfte
einsetzen wir müssen alle notwendigen
maßnahmen ergreifen
das gilt für die bundesregierung das
gilt für alle politisch verantwortlichen
aber es gilt auch für die bürgerinnen
und bürger die 380 millionen menschen
die in unserem land leben
denn es geht um den schutz gerade auch
ältere menschen menschen mit
vorerkrankungen sogenannter vulnerable
gruppen wie man heute sagt und da sind
unsere solidarität unsere vernunft unser
herz füreinander schon auf eine probe
gestellt von der ich mir wünsche dass
wir diese probe auch bestehen den frau
bundeskanzlerin herr minister vielen
dank frau bundeskanzlerin meine damen
und herren unser oberstes ziel ist und
bleibt es die ausbreitung des virus in
deutschland und in europa einzudämmen zu
verlangsamen um das gesundheitssystem zu
fördern ist funktionsfähig zu halten das
habe ich am montag gesagt auch in den in
einer regierungserklärung am mittwoch
das ist das was uns seit vielen wochen
in dem was wir tun in der
gesundheitspolitik in der arbeit mit dem
robert koch institut zusammen mit den
bundesländern und den institutionen den
krankenhäusern vor ort das ist das was
uns leitet dann ist es wichtig dass
diese botschaft wir gemeinsam auch immer
wieder auch ihren jeden herantragen in
die gesellschaft tragen die langsamer
sich das virus ausbreitet in deutschland
desto besser kann das gesundheitssystem
damit umgehen das ist genau das worum es
geht das virus ist da wir werden damit
umgehen müssen und die frage wie schnell
es sich verbreitet wird maßgeblich
darüber entscheiden wie gut wir im
gesundheitssystem damit umgehen können
denn je weniger menschen sich
gleichzeitig anstecken desto besser
können nehmen die ärztinnen und ärzte
und pflegekräfte in die pflegekräfte in
krankenhäusern dann tatsächlich auch
angemessen und gut behandeln wichtig ist
nämlich dass die symptome die mit dieser
harten wegs erkrankt
verbunden sind ja alles bekannte
symptome sind keine symptome mit denen
das gesundheitswesen nicht jeden tag
vielfach umgehen würde
aber gerade bei schweren verläufen etwa
eine lungenentzündung und den was dann
auch an intensiv medizin und
beatmungsgeräten daraus resultieren kann
genau dort ist sozusagen der engpass in
der versorgung und sagen dass wir mit
28.000 intensivbetten und davon etwa
25.000 mit beatmungsgeräten schon in
relation zur bevölkerungsgröße ein
vergleichsweise gut bis sehr gut
ausgestattet das gesundheitssystem haben
gleichwohl natürlich diese betten im
moment auch ja auch an vielen stellen
genutzt werden es wäre erklärt und
insofern ist es eben auch dort die große
aufgabe dort zu verlangsamen um diese
kapazitäten zu erhalten deshalb haben
wir dazu aufgerufen großveranstaltungen
abzusagen und unseren alltag zu ändern
jeder einzelne für sich aber auch die
gesellschaft insgesamt das gilt auch für
unternehmen für behörden das gilt für
uns alle und für jeden an seiner und
ihrer stelle insofern das will ich
ausdrücklich sagen es ist gut dass auch
berlin sich entschlossen hat das
fussball spiel ohne zuschauer
stattfinden zu lassen ich bin sehr
dankbar dass viele bundesländer gestern
schon mit kabinettsbeschlüssen auch
durch entsprechende polizei rechtliche
verfügungen eben diese grenze von 1000
teilnehmern für großveranstaltungen
entsprechend umgesetzt haben ich nehme
wahr dass auch die bürgerinnen und
bürger aber auch die verantwortlichen
vor ort mit einem solchen klaren maßstab
eben auch deutlich leichter umgehen
können wenn wir ihn gemeinsam
durchtragen ich bin dankbar dafür dass
wir genau auf dem weg dahin sind ich
will aber auch zusätzlich dazu sagen
dass das nicht heißt dass alles unter
1000 teilnehmer per se stattfinden
sollte das hängt natürlich dann auch von
der intensität der teilnehmerzahl und
anderen parametern ab
die tanzveranstaltung des rock konzert
ist was anderes als die semester prüfung
wo man ein meter auseinander setzt auch
das bleibt weiterhin natürlich im
einzelfall zu beurteilen ich weiß etwa
beim fußball duster vielen fans das herz
blutet aber ich vertraue auf die
solidarität auch und gerade der fußball
fans und fußballbegeisterten mit
denjenigen in der gesellschaft die wir
besonders schützen müssen und wollen
das sind die chronisch kranken das sind
die älteren für die man besonders hohes
risiko für einen schweren verlauf da ist
ich will auch sagen wenn man die zahl
hört 80% milde bis keine symptome
insbesondere für die jüngeren wenn sie
sonst keine vorerkrankungen haben ein
sehr geringes risiko könnte ja jemand
jüngeres denken wir gar nicht betroffen
was habe ich denn damit zu tun kann
einfach weiter machen wie bisher
und ich finde wichtig dass wir das in
die gesellschaft in die familien tragen
müssen dass es hier um den schutz der
anderen geht innerhalb der familie um
die eltern die großeltern und innerhalb
der gesellschaft dass wir alle auf ein
stück alltag verzichten um andere zu
schützen und selbst zu schützen aber vor
allem auch andere zu schützen und wenn
wir das jeder für sich in der familie im
alltag entscheiden aber eben auch für
uns als gesellschaft abwehr mit blick
auf großveranstaltungen das besonnen
machen und verantwortungsvoll mit blick
auf die familienfeier mit der frage ob
konzert oder kinobesuche anstehen dann
können wir tatsächlich einen unterschied
machen um die verbreitung dieses virus
entsprechend einzudämmen
ich bin sehr dankbar dass auch im
öffentlichen leben viele unternehmen
sich entschieden haben
zur heimarbeit home office über zu gehen
wo es möglich ist es ist nicht überall
möglich aber da wo es möglich ist es
auch möglich zu machen dass die
arbeitsunfähigkeit die krankschreibung
jetzt vorübergehend deutlich erleichtert
wird auch uns telefonisch möglich zu
machen damit niemand in die praxis dann
gehen muss dass viele firmen pläne auch
haben was hygieneregeln und anderes
angeht
auch das macht natürlich dann ein
unterschied und das sind kluge
entscheidungen im interesse der firma
der mitarbeiter aber eben auch der
gesamten gesellschaft insgesamt wir als
bundesregierung arbeiten daran diese
entscheidung zu unterstützen indem wir
rahmenbedingungen
die dieses entscheiden leichter machen
auch die frage wie wir wirtschaftliche
rahmenbedingungen schaffen wird ein
thema noch in den nächsten tagen sein um
die entscheider vor ort in ja
wirtschaftlich schwierigen
entscheidungen zu bestärken
gesundheit geht vor ökonomischen fragen
gleichwohl müssen wir natürlich
ökonomische fragen im blick behalten und
die folge der entscheidung klar ist
unser zusammenleben muss trotz dieser
epidemie funktionieren muss und wird
weitergehen und deswegen ist es wichtig
die balance immer zu halten uns auch zu
schaffen zwischen einschnitten und
einschränkungen und verzicht und einem
alltag der weitergeht vielen dank
sehr geehrte frau bundeskanzlerin sie
der minister meine damen und herren
lassen sich aus wissenschaftlicher sicht
diese epidemie einordnen wir sind seit
dem 6 januar im institut dabei diese
weltweite situation intensiv zu
analysieren mit zunehmender intensität
wir sind deshalb in der lage eine
einschätzung zu geben darüber wie sich
diese krankheit ausbreitet und wir
wissen und das hat die verbundes
kanzlerin eben zu recht gesagt dass es
sich um einen pandemischen virus handelt
also ein virus das 60 bis 70 prozent der
menschen infizieren wird was wir nicht
wissen ist in welcher geschwindigkeit
das geschieht aber ich denke jeder von
ihnen kann sich überlegen ihr lang
länger dies dauert desto besser ist dies
zum einen weil dann die chance wächst
dass ein impfstoff im nächsten jahr zur
verfügung steht zum anderen weil die
chance besteht dass therapeutika
verfügbar sind und natürlich ein großer
aspekt ist einfach der dass auch die
anzahl der betroffenen menschen weniger
wird die das gesundheitssystem dann
versorgen kann
das ist ganz klar denn das sind alles
maßnahmen und rahmenbedingungen die wir
im kopf haben müssen wenn man sich die
rahmenbedingungen anschaut dann ist es
sehr wichtig dass wir systematisch
vorgehen bei der methodik diese
verlangsamung des virus zu
rechnen wir müssen also den die
ausbeutung verlangsamt ein solches virus
verbreitet sich nicht wie eine welle
durch deutschland sondern in bestimmten
regionen das sehen die zurzeit ja in
europa etwa ich werde oft gefragt warum
sind in italien schon so viele menschen
verstorben warum sind es in deutschland
erst zwei was macht ihr deutschen anders
als die italienischen kollegen nun der
punkt ist einfach der dass wir von
vornherein sehr systematisch unsere
ärzte dazu aufgerufen haben personen zu
testen wir haben glücklicherweise ein
system in deutschland indem wir
testungen in einem hohen maße zur
verfügung stellen können so dass wir
einfach in einer frühen phase
in diesem beginnende epidemie
hineinschauen können
und wenn sie sich eine epidemie
vorstellen wie eine kurve wie hoch oder
wie flach die römer ist dann gibt es
länder in europa die sind eben in der
kurve einfach schon weiter links
tschuldigung weiter rechts wir sind
schon weiter in dieser epidemie
wir sind eben noch sehr weit links aber
wir werden auch weiter in diese epidemie
hinein kommen das heißt bei uns werden
natürlich auch die fallzahlen steigen
natürlich werden bei uns auch mehr
menschen noch sterben
und wir werden auch viele schwere
krankheitsverläufe das heißt also was
müssen wir tun und das haben wir uns
natürlich nicht nur überlebt sondern das
sind analysen das sind vor allen dingen
auch austausch mit anderen ländern die
ja bereits betroffen sind stärker oder
weniger stark betroffen sind das wird
auf der ebene der gesundheitsminister
geschieht geschieht natürlich auf der
ebene der nationalen
gesundheitsinstitute wie dem robert koch
institut
wir lernen sehr viel voneinander wir
tauschen uns aus erarbeiten gemeinsam
konzepte und so sehen sie auf der
website des robert-koch-instituts eine
zunahme von empfehlungen die auch
angepasst werden das der zweite schritt
diese empfehlungen werden natürlich auch
den gegebenheiten angepasst wenn es
darum geht wer kontaktpersonen sind wie
kontaktpersonen untersucht werden sollen
wie das gesundheitssystem mit diesen
kontaktpersonen umzugehen hat das sind
systematischen vorgehensweise die auf
analysen beruhen die wir im eigenen land
erheben und analysen
in anderen ländern erhoben werden diese
daten werden ausgetauscht und konzepte
werden ausgetauscht und miteinander
gesprochen und ein aspekt ist also die
verlangsamung dass die wir seit vielen
wochen wirklich immer wieder betonen
und das wird auch immer so bleiben wie
lange diese epidemie auch über unser
land geht es wird monate dauern sicher
vielleicht auch jahre
je länger es dauerte nicht sage es
nochmal desto besser ist dies und wir
haben nun eine gruppe von dem wir wissen
dass sie besonders schwere erkrankungen
haben werden wenn sie infiziert wenn die
chance dass sie besonders für
erkrankungen haben werden ist für
diejenigen die wir mit als chronisch
kranke sehen und die alten und
hochaltrigen und das heißt es muss unser
ziel dann diese gruppen besonders zu
schützen
wie kann man sich schützen man kann sie
natürlich am leichtesten dadurch
schützen dass man ihnen eben keine
infektionsgefahr aussetzt wenn sie
darüber nachdenken dass man zum beispiel
bestimmte veranstaltung nicht mehr
versucht ich glaube dann ist jedem klar
dass natürlich auf einer
großveranstaltung infizierte personen
viel mehr personen andere infizieren
können als wenn diese großveranstaltung
die stattfinden und das gilt natürlich
genauso wie das zusammenkommen von
älteren menschen und wir erarbeiten
gerade auch mit kolleginnen kollegen aus
dem ausland bestimmte empfehlungen wie
wir diese gruppe besonders schützen
können der zweite aspekt also der dritte
also nach der verlangsamung der schutz
der besonders sogenannten vulnerable
gruppen ist der aspekt auf den wir auch
immer wieder hinweise nicht langer zeit
dass die krankenhäuser sich wirklich
darauf vorbehalten
dass sie sich darauf vorbereiten dass
das klientel die patienten die zu ihm
kommen eben andere sein werden es wird
mehr patienten geben mit schweren
atemwegserkrankungen in gelungenen
zimmer und diese patienten müssen eben
intensiver versorgt werden
sie müssen auch ein teil dieser
patienten muss eben auch intensiv
medizinisch versorgt werden und auch
beatmet werden darum ist es so wichtig
dass wir den anteil dieser patienten so
gering wie möglich halten damit das
gesundheitssystem damit die
krankenhäuser in
frage sind die patienten zu versorgen
und das ist unsere aufforderung also
alle diese entscheidungsträger die
landräte die bürgermeister die
krankenhäuser müssen sich darauf
vorbereiten dass mehr patienten da sein
werden
wir sind am anfang einer epidemie und
dass sie ihre geschäftspläne so
einrichten ihre strategien so einrichten
dass sie sich möglichst mit möglichst
vielen dieser patienten umgehen können
um so möglichst viele patienten eine
gute medizinische versorgung auch
wirklich zur verfügung stellen können
danke vielen dank herr wähler bevor wir
zu allen fragen kommen will ich mal kurz
drei grundregeln sagen erstens jahr eine
beschränkung bis 12.45 weil
anschlusstermin die minister dann effekt
befehlen zweitens auch und meiner frage
liste kann ich jetzt schon sehen dass es
viele viele fragen gibt würde bitten
also eine frage und gegebenenfalls eine
nachfrage zu stellen und fritz ich kann
nicht versprechen dass wir derzeit alle
dran gekommen
jetzt kommen wir zu den fragen und herr
müller hat die erste frage wie ist es
aus ihrer sicht um die
verantwortlichkeit und das
verantwortungsbewusstsein der fußball
bundesligisten bestellt wenn die
vereinigung auch die deutsche fußball
liga nur unter äußersten druck bereit
sind in der ohne zuschauer auszutragen
und situationen wie sie haben eine
außergewöhnliche lage würden sie sich
mehr durchgriffsrechte des bundes auf
länder und kommunen in diesen solchen
ausserordentlichen lagen wünschen also
wir arbeiten jetzt mit der rechtslage
wir haben alles andere kann man später
mal diskutieren wie die dinge sind aber
jetzt arbeiten wir mit der und ich habe
auch die erfahrung gemacht in anderen
situationen zum beispiel in der großen
banken und wirtschaftskrise die wir
hatten 2008 2009 dass wir immer
miteinander klargekommen sind auch eine
exzellente zusammenarbeit damals in der
großen herausforderung der flüchtlinge
hatten wir können es gibt viel
verantwortungsbewusstsein auf allen
ebenen und ich kann mich dem pauschalen
der kritik wie sie jetzt gemacht haben
auch nicht anschließend ich muss ihnen
ganz ehrlich sagen wenn jetzt ein
fußballspiel ohne zuschauer stattfinden
soll dann muss kann das polizei
rechtlich angeordnet werden und ich habe
nicht gehört dass die bundesliga hat
sich dem widersetzen sollten die nächste
frage geht an herrn trinken und nicht
welches mikrofon
ja frau bundeskanzlerin ich hätte ganz
gern noch mal zu der telefonschalte
gestern gefragt es gibt ja den vorschlag
von frau von der leyen dass die staaten
damit man schnell liquidität bekommen
für dieses 25 milliarden paket auf die
rückzahlung der nicht genutzten eu
mittel verzichten das würde heißen dass
deutschland auch darauf verzichtet
einige milliarden in diesem jahr zurück
zu bekommen werden sie bereit dazu dass
deutschland dieser regelung zustimmt und
was heißt die von ihnen genannte
flexibilität beim stabilitätspakt heißt
dass das neue regelung nötig sind um zb
defizit grenzen zu überschreiten oder
glauben sie dass mit den derzeitigen
regelungen die eu und die
mitgliedstaaten diese krise in den griff
bekommen also ich glaube dass der
stabilitätspakt auch für
außergewöhnliche situationen ausreichend
flexibilität hat und das bedeutet eben
dass ein land wie italien das ja
sicherlich wo das thema stabilität
faktoren eine rolle spielt dass wir dem
natürlich selbstverständlich nicht sagen
dass es ist ein gesundheitssystem jetzt
nicht investieren kann weil wir schon
regel beim stabilitätspakt haben es ist
eine außergewöhnliche situation unser
grundgesetz unser schön bremse alle
rechtlichen instrumente sind für solche
situationen ja haben sie vorkehrungen
getroffen und das soll auch beim
stabilitätspakt zu sein was die
rückzahlung der nicht rückzahlung an die
mitgliedstaaten der übrig gebliebenen
mittel anbelangt da müssen wir uns das
natürlich genau angucken
man kann entweder die mitgliedstaaten
bitten schneller etwas zu überweisen und
trotzdem die rückzahlung einzubehalten
wir müssen jetzt gucken dass in einer
notsituation nicht dinge die schon immer
gewünscht wurden weil man sie gerne
hätte zum beispiel seitens des
europäischen parlamentes zur gewohnheit
werden sondern wir müssen auf die
außergewöhnliche situation mit
außergewöhnlichen mitteln reagieren
da werden wir das notwendige tun das
haben wir alle gesagt aber wir werden
jetzt auch nicht sozusagen dinge machen
die dann in den normalen verlauf wieder
hingehen aber ich mache mir keine oder
es wird keine probleme geben das von der
kommission vorgeschlagene
investitionsprogramm auch zu realisieren
das wird an deutschland nicht scheitern
laut bundeskanzlerin was die fingern was
die finanzen betrifft würden sie haben
es gerade von einer notsituation
gesprochen wer in dieser situation es
dann möglich nicht an dieser schwarzen
null so stark festzuhalten und an sie
beide als cdu-politiker werde es ein
drama wenn am 25 april kein cdu
vorsitzender gewählt wird sondern dieser
parteitag weil er ja auch über 1000
gäste delegierte usw hat verschoben
werden würde
also ich bin ja nicht mehr cdu
vorsitzende
aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
die cdu sich nicht an die regeln die wir
uns im gesellschaftlichen leben auch
auferlegen erhalten wird und deshalb
wird man das zum entsprechenden
zeitpunkt entscheiden wir haben jetzt
irgendwie den elften märz dann 28 april
sonne weile hin aber ich kann mehr
fünfundzwanzigster april es noch eine
weile hin
aber wir werden sie zeitgerecht
informieren dass andere schauen sie wir
tun jetzt das was notwendig ist der
haushaltsausschuss hat schon bis zu
einer milliarde mehr investitionen
freigegeben um ins gesundheitssystem zu
investieren die fragen unterstützung der
entwicklung andere fragen und da werden
wir nicht jeden tag fragen was bedeutet
das jetzt für unser defizit das ist eine
besondere situation und wir werden das
was notwendig ist tun und
glücklicherweise ist deutschland auch
relativ robust aufgestellt wurde
agentur für arbeit hat hohe rücklagen
kann beim kurzarbeitergeld agieren und
bürgschaften oder sonstwas zu geben sind
wir werden das tun damit wir gut durch
diese situation kommen und dann werden
wir uns am ende anschauen was das
bedeutet hat für unseren aus wie das
andere geht jetzt erst mal vor frau
bundeskanzlerin der bankenkrise 2008
haben sie eine garantie für die
spareinlagen ausgesprochen das geht
natürlich heute nicht das eine ganz
andere situation
sie haben aber selber gesagt das herz
der menschen die solidarität sei auf die
probe gestellt welches mittel hat denn
die bundesregierung und vielleicht auch
sie persönlich mit so einem auftritt um
dieses herz zu stärken und die
solidarität unter den menschen die zum
teil schon desinfektionsmittel clown in
den krankenhäusern zu stärken welche
apple ist heute der ire haben die
eigenschaft dass oft über negative
vorfälle etwas stärker berichtet wird
als überhaupt positive und es gibt viele
viele positive erfahrungen und die
werden wir auch hervorheben und die
werden wir stärken und ich finde die den
beitrag den der staat und die akteure
des staates leisten können unter anderem
auch die politiker ist dass wir das
notwendige tun dass wir es schnell tun
dass wir es besonnen tun dass wir
entschlossen sind und vor allen dingen
dass wir uns auch an den rat halten wo
wir nicht die experten sind sondern
andere die experten sind und ich glaube
das ist ein beitrag dazu dass andere
auch sagen ich möchte meine
verantwortung auch wahrnehmen
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben die
wichtigkeit der europäischen solidarität
und koordination angesprochen aber wenn
man sich die maßnahmen der letzten tagen
oder wochen anschaut ist deshalb sehr
unsolidarisch und unkoordiniert also man
denkt beispielsweise an die schließung
der grenzen in österreich nach italien
oder die die tatsache dass deutschland
diplomatischen eklat mit der schweiz
provoziert hat mit dieser
ohne vorwarnung auf haltung von von dem
lastwagen wie können sie werden jetzt
hier in dieser krise die europäische
solidarität aufrechterhalten und haben
sie italien konkrete hilfe angeboten mit
finishes personal oder mach ja also ich
habe ja erst schon aus meiner
perspektive gesagt wie unser export
erlaubnis oder exportgenehmigung zu
verstehen ist weil es da auch
missverständnisse gab die entspannen
kann gleich noch einmal ein wort sagen
zu dem was sie da eben erwähnt haben ein
blick auf die schweiz
ansonsten ist es glaube ich wichtig dass
wir uns unter den europäischen
regierungschefs darüber austauschen was
sind titel und wirksame maßnahmen und
was nicht und wir sind jedenfalls in
deutschland der meinung dass
grenzschließungen keine adäquate antwort
auf die herausforderung sind wohl aber
natürlich maßnahmen wenn man sagt ich
komme aus einer als krisenregion
eingestuften region dass ich mich dann
so verhalten dass ich mich nie als
nächstes in eine veranstaltung von 955
leuten hinein bewegen sondern vielleicht
haus quarantäne oder ähnliches mache das
sind angepasste maßnahmen und zu dem
anderen sagte zudem einen noch ergänzend
wir haben gestern oder vorgestern
aufgrund der entwicklung in italien auch
zum risikogebiet insgesamt erklärt und
damit verbunden den aufruf an alle
bürgerinnen und bürger die zurück kommen
aus italien
in den nächsten zwei wochen alle
kontakte zu anderen auf das dringend
notwendige zu reduzieren
im zweifel zu hause zu bleiben von zu
hause zu arbeiten
auch die kinder zu hause zu lassen über
sie zwei wochen und falls ich symptome
ergeben eben dann den arzt anzurufen
oder das gesundheitsamt also dann
im sehr gezielt sozusagen auch die
bürgerinnen und bürger bekräftigen in
dem was sie tun und wie sie damit
umgehen das ist doch die botschaft die
die grenzen pauschal zu schließen im
übrigen verhindert das ja nicht was da
passiert es ist im land und in dem
moment wo sie grenz maßnahmen wieder
reduzieren fängt es auch wieder an
ich verstehe dass an der italienischen
grenze im moment eine besondere
situation ist und ich verstehe dass man
dann da vorübergehend auch zu kontrollen
kommt ist aber etwas anderes als
grundsätzliche trends maßnahmen das
finde ich sehr wichtig und das war ja
das verständnis was wir auch
gesundheitsminister seit ich jedenfalls
über mehrere räte und treffen immer
gehabt haben in europa das pauschale
grenz maßnahmen und einschränkungen des
reiseverkehrs unbenommen von einzelnen
maßnahmen situationsbezogen wenn nicht
angezeigt ist zu den masken und dem
exportbeschränkungen
es ist so das ist eine
exportbeschränkung ist heißt aber nicht
dass keine exporte mehr möglich sind
es war nur bis dahin so dass teilweise
händler mit geldkoffer bargeld
aufgetaucht sind bei den unternehmen und
angefangen haben masken zu kaufen und
das ist seit exportbeschränkung vorbei
weil es am ende nicht mehr danach gegen
wo ist der bedarf sondern wer zahlt am
meisten
und natürlich wollen wir unseren
europäischen nachbarn und partnerländern
auch helfen in der versorgung und sind
anders herum ja auch eingeborenen
lieferketten ist ja nicht so als wenn
eine exportbeschränkung in deutschland
nicht auch für lieferketten reziprok
folgen hätte und deswegen sind wir
gerade dabei sehr zügig noch in dieser
woche
ein verfahren auch zu setzen wo wir eben
im einzelfall und dann auch diese woche
schon die ersten entscheidungen zu
entscheidungen kommen wo die lkws die
teilweise an der grenze stehen mit den
masten ja dann auch tatsächlich ein
beispiel es angesprochen worden
natürlich jetzt ziel auch erreichen
sollen aber wir wollen schon dass das
feuer war der bar geldkoffer entscheidet
darüber wo die masken hingehen
dass das nicht mehr stattfinden
bundeskanzlerin auch noch mal zur
telefonschalte letzte nacht oder letzten
abend da hat ja offenbar die ezb chefin
lagarde ein ziemlich dramatisches bild
gezeichnet unter anderem auch davor
gewarnt dass diese krise ähnlich wie die
finanzkrise 2008 auswirkungen haben
könnte
stimmen sie mit dieser einschätzung
überein und sie sind ja nun erfahrene
krisenmanagerin auch schon der
finanzkrise welche schlussfolgerung
ziehen sie daraus für ihre jetzige
arbeit
wo sehen sie ähnlichkeiten und
unterschiede bei den der frage der
banken gehe dramatisch genug waren weil
sie natürlich die grundlage auf
funktionierendes wirtschaftssystem sind
hat man gewisse vorstellungen über die
kreditportfolios man hat also
eingrenzbar hre dinge die man kennt und
wo man auch weiß was kostet ist wie muss
man wie viel kapital muss man ein selbst
eine bank zu rekapitalisieren und
ähnliche dinge man kann also die werte
sehr viel besser bestimmen
hier hat man es mit einer
sache zu tun die man ja in ihrer wirkung
gar nicht von vornherein einschätzen
haben wir wissen nicht was für ihre
mobilität werden aufgebaut wie lange
halten diese immunität
wir wissen nicht genau wie schnell
steckt sich dass wir schnell sind gehen
die infizierungen also man weiß jetzt
schon etwas mehr
wir wissen zum beispiel noch nicht
richtig das haben sie selbst hier
nachverfolgen kann an dem auch an dem
was professor drosten gesagt hat wie
temperatur abhängig ist die
infektionsrate auch das kriegt man jetzt
erst langsam mit also verhält sich das
sie im normalen grippe zeiten dass es im
sommer weniger wird oder muss man doch
davon ausgehen dass es temperatur
unabhängiger ist also wir müssen mit
viel mehr unbekannten noch agieren und
deshalb ist die situation schon noch
eine andere aber wie in allen solchen
krisensituationen ist besonnenheit und
entschlossenheit das notwendige zu tun
glaube ich wichtig ich teile die
einschätzung von christine lagarde ich
musste ja auch sehr ernst nehmen und was
er eben aufpassen müssen ist dass wir
dafür ist es eben auch wichtig dass es
keine überforderung oder dramatischen
überforderungen
des gesundheitssystems kommt dass wir
erst einmal den die krise als solche die
die herausforderung durch das virus
einigermaßen gut bewerkstelligen
damit aus die jedoch zusätzliche
verunsicherung in die wirtschaft
hineingetragen wird denn wir wissen dass
verunsicherungen im wirtschaftsbereich
dann auch psychologischer folgen haben
können und deshalb ist so wichtig dass
wir die qualitäts zusagen machen dass
wir sagen wir helfen kleinen und
mittleren unternehmen insbesondere in
dieser situation das ist ja auch eine
ganz andere betroffenheit jetzt die
tourismusbranche ist betroffen der
hotel- und gaststättengewerbe ist
betroffen während wer vorher uns eher
mit den großen dax-unternehmen
zusammengesetzt haben das mag auch alles
noch kommen
aber wir haben hier als erster
betroffenheit ganz andere bereiche auch
in der wirtschaft nehmen das sehr ernst
denn unsere unser ganzes globales
wirtschaftsleben ist sozusagen eine
immer fragiles konstrukt was auf äußere
erschütterungen nicht so gerne reagiert
und vor allem wo wir die reaktion auch
nicht kennen und wir müssen alles tun
damit es gut und überschaubar reagiert
und das kann nur durch koordiniertes
internationales handeln erfolgen und
eine volkswirtschaft wie die deutsche
die extrem exportabhängig ist ist
natürlich von globalen herausforderungen
noch mal stärker betroffen als eine sehr
aufsicht konzentrierte volkswirtschaft
herr schuler frau bundeskanzlerin warum
melden sie sich erst jetzt zu wort
hätten sie das viel früher zur chefsache
machen müssen und herr sparen erwarten
sie eine situation in der ausgewählt
werden muss wer eine behandlung erhält
und wer nicht also ich würde mal sagen
der bundesgesundheitsminister weiß darf
nicht erst seit heute sache kümmere wann
ich wo dazu etwas sagen das ist eine
entscheidung treffe ich nach den
umständen und nach den sachverhalten und
ich finde dass die gestrige video
schaltkonferenz ist eine wunderbare
gegeben
zeit ist auch mit der
bundespressekonferenz zu sprechen vorher
haben viele viele andere gespräche
stattgefunden wie auch wichtig sind und
auch weiter stattfinden an dem auch
hinzufügen dass die frau bundeskanzlerin
ich in den gesprächen die werden vom
eigentlich ab januar die situation mit
der nötigen ernsthaftigkeit um klarheit
ja auch immer wieder besprochen haben
mit dem was ist jeweils aber auch mit
dem was sich entwickeln kann aber es ist
eben eine sehr dynamische lage wie wir
in den letzten zwei drei wochen gesehen
haben natürlich das hinzufügen darf ist
die geht der eigentliche teilte dynamik
nicht wahrscheinlich noch vor uns mit
denen was sich in den nächsten wochen
und monaten denn dann auch entwickeln
wird und das bringt mich zum zweiten
teil ihrer frage das ist ja das
unbedingte ziel das wir situationen in
denen man reagieren müsste in dem man
tatsächlich entscheiden müsste wie kann
das gesundheitssystem jetzt tatsächlich
am besten helfen mit seinen ressourcen
dass wir die vermeiden wollen und dass
wir da alle nicht hinkommen hat was
damit zu tun jetzt wie wir jetzt agieren
um die ausbreitung zu verlangen sei die
frage ob jetzt großveranstaltungen
stattfinden oder nicht hat was damit zu
tun welche situationen in den kliniken
entstehen können für die die am
dringendsten hilfe brauchen und hier am
schwächsten sind die frage wie wir im
alltag damit umgehen ob man mal bereit
ist bestimmte dinge zu verzichten den
club besuch und ich sage nochmal der 20
jährige mag sich sagen wird stört denn
wenn ich in den club gehe ich bin der
wenig risikogruppe aber wer dann
übermorgen kontakte hat hoffentlich zur
familie hat dann eben auch andere die
möglicherweise ins risiko kommt oder in
der schule oder in der uni oder wo auch
immer
und wenn das eigentlich nur eine aufgabe
ist sozusagen staatlicherseits sondern
wenn wir das gemeinsam als unsere
aufgabe als gesellschaft und jedes
einzelnen begreifen mitzuhelfen dass wir
in eine solche wie von ihnen
beschriebene lage nicht kommt dann kann
das eben auch gelingen schließt ja
manchmal auch nicht dass chinesische
zentralsystem in seinem umgang mit einer
epidemie besser wäre
aber er mag man manchmal zentral
maßnahmen gleich härter durchsetzen
können aber die frage auch bürgerinnen
und bürger zu bestärken mitzumachen und
mitmachen zu können und zu wollen
die chance haben wir jedenfalls in einem
in einer offenen pluralen gesellschaft
dann doch mehr
und genau darauf setzt sich und das ist
auch das was ich erlebe jeden tag in den
rückmeldung wenn das eine ist ja das was
immer auch richtig ist ja probleme zu
beschreiben
aber ich war gestern abend noch in der
charité kurzum mit pflegekräften ärzte
setzten in der notaufnahme zu sprechen
und ich erlebte einfach eine wahnsinnig
hohe bereitschaft sich zu engagieren und
mit uns gemeinsam diese lage zu meistern
wenn wir das in dem geiste machen dann
wird es gelingen die ganz schwierigen
situation bestmöglich zu vermeiden aber
garantien sage ich auch dazu garantien
gibt es keinen stopp besitzt
frau bundeskanzlerin heute wurde ja das
kurzarbeitergeld auf den weg gebracht
und noch weitere maßnahmen würden wir
einen koalitionsausschuss beschlossen
haben freitag treffen sie auch
wirtschaftsvertreter und vertreter der
arbeitnehmerschaft welche maßnahmen
hätten sie denn da noch anzubieten
es hieß ja nach dem koalitionsausschuss
wenn nötig können ja auch noch
draufsatteln
ja es wird ja ein freitag eine
bekanntmachung vom bundeswirtschafts und
finanzminister also von urlaubs und
peter altmaier geben wo der ganze
bereich der liquiditätshilfen noch mal
aufgerufen wird und dann haben wir jetzt
erstmal die maßnahmen die im augenblick
im raume stehen und wir werden dann
natürlich mit den wirtschaftsverbänden
am freitagabend auch darüber diskutieren
was aus deren sicht an rückmeldungen
dass und ob gegebenenfalls noch neue
instrumente hinzugefügt werden müssen
also auch das wird ein lernprozess sein
damit man nicht sagen so das war's und
was auch immer ihr jetzt kommt das
interessiert uns nicht sondern wenn im
wirtschaftsgeschehen dinge auf treffen
die wir gar nicht alle sehen können was
passiert zum beispiel auch an
unterbrochenen lieferketten durch
ausfälle in anderen ländern
wenn ganz norditalien zum beispiel in
einer schwierigen situation ist da gibt
es eine ganz enge verpflichtung der
wirtschaft mit süddeutschland zum
beispiel das können wir nicht alles
voraussehen und da wird man adäquat
darauf reagieren müssen aber wir werden
einen instrumentenkasten mit freitag am
freitag haben der erst mal auf das
vorhersehbare eine reaktion ist im
kochen im übrigen auch sehr ähnlich dem
was andere länder machen das
kurzarbeitergeld ist nun eine sache die
sehr wirksam ist sehr viel beruhigung
gibt das haben jetzt nicht alle länder
aber insgesamt ist das vorgehen unter
den großen volkswirtschaften der
europäischen union sehr ähnlich philipp
sandmann von rtl tv eine frage an die
bundeskanzlerin hier
wie geht es ihnen wenn sie jetzt in
diesen raum hier belegten hier sitzen ja
auch ein paar menschen ist zwar keine
großveranstaltung über 1000 leute aber
doch auch eine größere veranstaltung und
die zweite frage wenn sie erlauben an
herrn sparen und ein händler
gibt es denn schon erkenntnisse darüber
wie hoch die dunkelziffer denn sein
könnte weil es gibt ja wie sie auch
seien viele junge menschen die
möglicherweise sich bereits angesteckt
haben und das gar nicht wissen also wie
geht es mir erstens habe ich gesagt wenn
den fotografen nicht treten stück zurück
damit der abstand von 1 bis 1,5 metern
gebaut ist dann guck ich mir nach dem
mann nicht da so oft darauf aufmerksam
gemacht hat mir an wie viele von ihnen
sich irgendwie die hand im gesicht haben
ob man ja nicht haben soll und da fallen
mir auch einige auf und dann sage ich
noch schöner wäre sie könnten alle in
einem meter abstand sitzen aber das
können wir nicht überall gewährleisten
also so geht es mir
ansonsten freue ich mich
wenn ich sie alle gesund hier zu sehen
wenn wir bei den ganz praktischen dingen
sind weil der viele fragen was kann ich
machen
im grunde ist das verhalten so zu
empfehlen wie wenn man wüsste der neben
ein wo der mit einem raum oder im
haushalt hat zum beispiel grippe nicht
weil es ist wie grippe aber weil die
übertragungswege sind wie bei anderen
erkältungskrankheiten auch und wenn ich
weiß mein meinen partnern mein kind
meine eltern haben grippe ich bin
zusammen im haushalt oder mein kollege
hat möglicherweise symptome dann weiß
ich doch auch wie verhalte ich mich um
mich selbst zu schützen und es nicht
weiter zu geben und diese einfachen
verhaltensweisen die jeder kennt aus dem
alltag die sind genau wie jetzt helfen
wenn wir sie konsequent durchhalten und
dazu gehört vielleicht jetzt auch eine
längere phase und es fällt mir
persönlich auch sehr schwer
wo man sich etwas weniger mit dem
handschlag begrüßt das ist bei uns tief
drinnen kulturell das ist auch gut so
schöne geste aber vielleicht ist jetzt
mal den zeitraum wo war das etwas
reduzieren für einen längeren das ist
bis jetzt durch sind für einen längeren
bereich dafür eine sekunde länger in die
augen gucken und lächeln genau auf die
frage nach der doppelsitzer könnten also
die dunkel
die dunkelziffer kennen wir nicht genau
aber wir gehen davon aus dass in
deutschland nicht sehr hoch ist
das ist der grund ist ganz einfach das
hatte ihm erläutert die haben ja schon
mitte januar schon bestimmte
empfehlungen herausgegeben werden
getestet werden soll oder wer nicht
getestet werden soll wir haben ein sehr
systematisches testverfahren in
deutschland möglich gemacht und das ist
ja auch der grund warum wir so früh in
dieser epidemie reinschauen ja also es
will es noch mal betonen diese epidemie
ist am anfang
sie wird ja weitergehen aber wir schauen
früher ein das heißt also wir haben uns
früh erkannt und das ist der grund ist
eben dass wir noch keine hohe
dunkelziffer haben und das ist der
unterschied zu vielleicht dem einen oder
anderen land
wir alle werden in dieser phase kommen
wenn dieser berg größer wird
an fällen aber momentan haben wir noch
wenig fälle das ist ein großes glück
weil es damit ja auch gelingt wirklich
den krankenhäusern und den ärzten und
allen genügend zeit zu geben sich darauf
vorzubereiten das ist ein ganz ganz
guter zeit gewinnen und wir müssen nur
jetzt nennen den entscheidern wirklich
klar machen dass eben eine krise auf uns
zukommt und dass sie diese pläne
wirklich ernst nehmen und ihre
entsprechenden patientenströme so planen
und die krankenhäuser entsprechend
darauf vorbereiten wenn jetzt richtig
verstanden habe wird es ja auch einen
zeitpunkt geben wo man mal versuchen
wird eine repräsentative studie zu
machen durch untersuchung der antikörper
im blut um dann herauszufinden wer es
alles schon hatte und daraus dann auch
zu erkennen zu können wie viel das
vielleicht noch bekommen werden aber
dazu müssen wir natürlich noch ein paar
monate warten um jeden fall zeit also es
gibt eine reihe von tests und studien
die man natürlich sich ausgedacht hat
die concept.de und hier ist halt wichtig
dass das koordiniert funktioniert da
sind natürlich gerade auch die
universitätskliniken ganz ganz wichtiger
aspekt die natürlich bestimmte
kapazitäten haben forschungskapazitäten
haben und jetzt eben auch wichtig dass
das koordiniert geschieht und da spielt
natürlich das robert- koch- und sie doch
eine wichtige rolle
das sind auch teile der planungen die
wir durchführen und der telefonkonferenz
und der absprachen dass studien
synchronisiert werden wir werden ja auch
wenn es wenn es medikamente gibt
wirkstoffe die vielleicht eben dazu
beitragen dass eine krankheit besser
behandelt werden kann der schweregrad
reduziert werden kann
dann muss das natürlich in deutschland
so geschehen dass dann die
universitätsklinika gemeinsame
protokolle entwickeln und da ist es eben
auch wichtig dass am robert koch
institut mit integriert ist mit den
klinikern um das versucht zu
koordinieren
das ist eine große stärke in deutschland
wir haben ja 37 universitätsklinika mit
viel viel sachverstand und das alles
gehört zu diesen diesen aufgaben die im
hintergrund geschehen und wo sie sich
eben sicher sein können dass wir
versuchen all das mit mit bester
mit besten möglichkeiten nach bestem
wissen und gewissen in einem gemeinsamen
akt zu tun das indem auch solidarische
maßnahme wie natürlich auch in der
wissenschaftswelt gefragt sind wo es ja
doch oft darum geht dass man eben
konkurriert um bestimmte wissenschafts
ergebnis hier geht es darum dass man
gemeinsam projekte vermittelt um einen
möglichst hohen benefit für die
patienten zu haben sn die
bundeskanzlerin die haben das thema
erstattung und infektionsschutzgesetz
schon angesprochen wenn ich die juristen
richtig verstehe ist aber die frage der
staatshaftung das gefälle das behörden
das verbieten sechs ich da jetzt scheint
man sich ersparen sie haben in ihrer
letzten pressekonferenz auch dazu schon
eine bemerkung gemacht dann müsste man
vielleicht noch mal ran was ist dann
geplant
ja ich finde hier zu der letzten tage
noch folgen sagen morgen zur
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz habe ich
auch den chef der charité professor
krömer eingeladen der einen vorschlag
machen wird was die im verband der
universitätsklinika geforscht und
gemacht getan werden könnte dass da
wollen wir auch wirklich eng
zusammenarbeiten
die haftungsfragen ja da haben wir heute
früh noch mal drüber gesprochen es gibt
mehr unklarheiten als man denkt und ich
habe die justizministerin heute im
kabinett schon gebeten dass wir da die
fälle die uns jetzt auftreten
analysieren und dann auch klare
richtlinien dafür herausgeben auch wenn
man nur kurz ergänzen da was wir im kern
schaffen müssen ist dass es für
diejenigen die ja zum teil
wirtschaftlich folgenreiche
entscheidungen treffen mit
großveranstaltungen abzusagen ist ja gtb
abzusagen eine wirtschaftlich
folgenreiche entscheidung dass wir für
diejenigen dass wir die nicht alleine
lassen und dafür braucht erstmal
rechtliche eindeutigkeit und wenn man
das infektionsschutzgesetz liest denkt
man die gäbe ist und wenn man dann
tiefer einsteigt dann so ist das glaube
ich ist das gut morgen in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz blackout
das thema nochmal zu adressieren wie wir
da bund und länder gemeinsam zu einer
einheitlichen herangehensweise kommen
prozent und das ist ja das was peter
altmaier und olaf scholz in den blick
nehmen wie wir dann eben auch die
wirtschaftlichen folgen für die bereiche
insbesondere die von diesen absagen
betroffen sind wir in 200 denen auch
helfen jetzt durch diese schwierige zeit
das sind ja gastronomen
handwerksbetriebe die die messestände
bauen vieles andere mehr kritik geht das
natürlich gerade richtig rein und das
abzufedern macht am ende dann auch
entscheidungen leichter auf was zu
verzichten frau bundeskanzlerin wenn man
in die supermärkte geschaut und in die
leeren regale teilweise entscheidet es
vor allem drei warengruppen zu geben die
besonders nachgefragt werden im moment
das sind toilettenpapier teigwaren
nudeln und desinfektionsmittel haben sie
ein gewisses verständnis dafür für den
volksmund sagt man hamsterkäufe dazu und
ich würde gerne hand sparen haben die
darauf fragen für wie sinnvoll halten
sie es wenn man sich privatpersonen so
eine art vorrat an desinfektionsmitteln
zulegen also wir haben ja schon die
situation gehabt das ist fast gelächter
gab als der damalige innenminister
thomas sind eine sehr darüber gesprochen
hat dass es aus verschiedenen gründen
sinnvoll ist wenn man bestimmte vorräte
zu hause hat das ist jetzt kein aufruf
zum hamster und kauf und was man zum
teil an sozusagen spitzen des verhaltens
sieht das finde ich auch etwas
bedenklich aber dass man eine bestimmte
bevorratung hat das ist durch das
bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz zum
beispiel auch durchaus empfohlen
dennoch finde ich ist das auch genauso
wie in anderen bereichen man muss ja
jetzt nicht alle bereiche des
öffentlichen lebens einem stresstest
aussetzen um mal gucken wie man ungefähr
zehn bis hundertmal so viel kauft man
normalerweise kauft wie lange der vorrat
reicht sondern auch hier ist maß und
mitte glaube ich die richtige antwort
print desinfektionsmitteln übrigens auch
zu den masken alle jänicke und experten
sagen uns dass es für den hausgebrauch
nicht notwendig ist desinfektionsmittel
zur es reicht das intensive händewaschen
und intensiv heißt länger als zwei
sekunden intensiv mit seife und auch der
klassische op mundschutz den viele
tragen schützt sehr überschaubaren ist
so zu formulieren
es ist auch gar nicht notwendig wenn man
sich an die regeln hält die ich vorhin
mit blick auf atemwegserkrankungen
beschrieben habe
das gefährliche was nur dann entstanden
ist ist dass das nicht mehr verhandelt
desinfektionsmittel dann in den kliniken
für ärzte pflegekräfte in der
lebensmittelindustrie in den bereichen
wo es tatsächlich gebraucht wird weil da
auch nicht immer ein waschbecken so
intensiv genutzt werden kann und gleich
noch immer da ist das da engpässe
entstanden sind welches infektions
mitteln haben wir es geschafft und sind
noch dabei und der umsetzung ist ein
stück aufzulösen bei wie eine ausnahme
möglich gemacht haben das mit industrie
alkohol und das virus ist alkohol
sensibel heißt also kann damit leben
geschützt davor geschützt werden dass
wir industrie alkohol jetzt möglich
gemacht haben zu nutzen zur herstellung
von desinfektionsmitteln seine ausnahme
aus der biozid verordnung das bringt
entspannung damit könnten apotheken im
übrigen auch vor ort wieder herstellen
die chemische industrie hat gestern uns
noch berichtet dass sie auch bereit ist
und dabei ist kapazitäten umzustellen um
auch dort entsprechend zu produzieren
aber es bleibt dabei auch das in
freiheit von solidarität und miteinander
desinfektions und op masken sollten vor
allem für diejenigen da sein die sie für
ihre tägliche arbeit zum
für uns alle brauchen und das sind
zuvörderst ärzte und lediglich ein
journalist frau kanzlerin meine frage
ist ober die investitionen in der
forschung im medizinischen bereich
sie haben gerade von einer milliarde
extra im gesundheitssystem gesprochen da
ist mehrere investitionen institute oder
forschungsinstitute wie robert koch
institut für forschung diese krise
andere frage an herrn spahn in run
konnte zur komplette abwicklung des
bundesgebiet wie in italien oder die
situation ist hier anderes also was die
forschung anbelangt können er mit ihr
erst beginnen an einem impfstoff wenn
man das virus erst mal kennt gott sei
dank es ist sequenziert und kann man
kann darauf reagieren und wir haben
glücklicherweise norwegen hat hier eine
führende rolle gespielt seit 2016 eine
koalition von akteuren das sind
unternehmen dass es die melinda und
gates stiftung das sind staaten die sich
zusammengeschlossen haben um in solchen
fällen auch bereit zu sein zum beispiel
impfstoffe zu entwickeln da ist jetzt
ein programm aufgelegt worden
deutschland hat einen
finanzierungsanteil an dieser cp allianz
von 13 prozent und die 140 milliarden
die der millionen die man dafür braucht
die haben wir jetzt gegeben die
milliarde geht nicht nur in forschung
glaube ich sondern auch in der
züchtigung bestimmter gesundheitssystem
fähigkeiten aber dazu kann jens spahn
mehr sagen also nimmt der forschung
haben wir natürlich ein fokus auf der
beschaffung von masken darauf haben wir
uns ja geeinigt auch das eine
ausnahmesituation der bund jetzt auch
alles daran setzt und dass man auch
persönlich zu beschaffen habe ich sage
ihnen auch ist es schwer wenn
gleichzeitig auf der ganzen welt starten
krankenhäuser und privatpersonen etwa op
déi op masken brauchen wir gar nicht
originär für des kroner virus aber für
den aufrechterhalten von op betrieb
regulären brauchen wir halt op masken in
diesem land und wenn die knapp werden
dann hat das folgen für die versorgung
das ist der eine teil finanzielles
andere sind intensiv kapazitäten wichtig
finde ich wir haben fürs
robert-koch-institut auch noch
kurzfristig zusätzlich geld bekommen um
jetzt auch gezielt für diese lage auch
fallstudien und anderes angeht geld zu
haben was ich mir wünschte wäre wenn wir
in europa noch stärker miteinander auch
des cdc also das europäische
robert-koch-institut sozusagen noch
weiter stärken und das robert koch wir
haben heute nachmittag auch video call
mit einigen gesundheitsministern einiger
länder und ich kann ihnen sagen dass
gerade in den kleineren mitgliedstaaten
ist ein hohes interesse gibt an der
expertise des robert-koch-instituts
teilzuhaben deswegen können wir das
nachher auch intensiv machen
das zeigt aber dass wir auch da in
europa vielleicht kräfte für die zukunft
auch in der haushaltsplanung noch
mitnehmen können zur frage abregelung
wissen sie das ist ja die frage wenn sie
ein ich habe vorhin schon mal angriff
wenn sie einen bereich total ab regeln
und dann lüften sie das wieder so zu
sein dann kommt das virus rein es ist
nicht sie verhindern ist nicht es kommt
sie können mit keine abregelung maßnahme
ist verhindert außerdem ganz allein auf
der insel und lassen die man mehr drauf
dann vielleicht und deswegen ist die
frage wie verlangsamen wer das ist die
entscheidende frage nicht sozusagen
durch durch das man mal phasenweise in
bestimmten regionen zu entscheidungen
kommt und um irgendwo zu sagen auch die
bürger bitte zu hause und so okay aber
nicht generell
das gilt übrigens recht erstmal
kurzeinführung dafür kindergärten und
schulen die debatte ja auch sehe ich
finde wir sollten in einer ersten stufe
zuerst auf das verzichten wo es leichter
ist zu verzichten
und es ist leichter auf fußballspiele so
wichtig die den fans sind was ich gut
verstehen aber für uns als gesellschaft
doch insgesamt und vielen einzelnen
leichter auf fußballspiele oder konzerte
oder club besucher zu verzichten
als für die frage habe ich eine
betreuung und eine beschulung für meine
kinder
weil das für pflegekräfte polizisten
ärzte busfahrer die das öffentliche
leben und viele andere auch aufrecht
erhaltene folge hat und übrigens wenn
sie das infektionsschutz frage nehmen
wenn die kinder dann bei oma sind um es
wirklich so zu sagen kann wir jetzt
länger darüber diskutieren ob das nicht
vielleicht sogar eher folgen in die
falsche richtung hat also dann wird
jetzt spontan was organisiert wo man
dann die kinder sozusagen betreut weiß
und ob die lösungen die dann gefunden
werden
tatsächlich diejenigen sind die helfen
die verbreitung des virus zu reduzieren
darüber kann man glaube ich zumindest
mal länger diskutieren und wenn ich dann
manchmal so leichthändig einige im mit
der forderung sie einfach mal alle
schulen und kindergärten zu dann bin ich
mir nicht ganz sicher ob dann immer zu
ende auch alle folgen gedacht werden
dass man das regional mal macht sie
heinsberg macht sinn flächendeckend bin
ich sehr zurückhaltend frau
bundeskanzlerin sie haben gesagt
föderalismus ist nicht dafür da dass man
verantwortung weg schiebt nun scheint
sich ja besonders der berliner senat
hier sehr abwartend und zögerlich
verweist auf das morgige treffen bei
ihnen müsste nicht gerade hier schneller
gehandelt werden auch mit blick auf das
kommende wochenende müssten da nicht
auch die klubs geschlossen werden ich
werde jetzt keine einzelnen anderen
machen ich habe gehört dass ein fußball
spielen und auch ohne zuschauer statt
findet obwohl die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz noch nicht
stattgefunden hat der kultursenator hat
hier sehr konsequent etwas zu opern und
theater und kulturveranstaltungen gesagt
insofern will ich jetzt auch hier
überhaupt niemanden an pranger stellen
ich habe gesagt für der realismus hat
chancen
wir können den zentral auch reagieren in
bestimmten regionen wir haben durch den
föderalismus eine fielen
instanzen viel breiter in der fläche
aufgestellte infrastruktur für bestimmte
dinge wir haben nicht nur in der
hauptstadt und noch zwei städte und dann
allen anderen sind bestimmte fähigkeiten
da nicht nicht da zum beispiel unser
universitätssystem 37
universitätsklinika das bietet chancen
aber es bedeutet auch dass jeder an
seiner stelle eben dann auch
verantwortung übernimmt und es kann eben
nicht von berlin aus verboten werden
etwas zu tun aber es kann sehr wohl von
berlin empfohlen werden etwas zu tun und
ich finde dass ist die das doch die
allermeisten auch das aufnehmen und
annehmen und so war sehr dankbar sind
wenn sie diese empfehlungen haben
bekommen nun die meldung dass berlin
alles über 1000 bis ostern
und da sagt nein aber es zeigt doch nur
dass doch reagiert in einem gemeinsamen
prozess sind ich würde es natürlich
nicht nicht erlebt ich habe gestern noch
in einer schalte mit den 16
gesundheitsministern der länder
gesprochenen diskutiert und das ist ein
sehr jenseits der fach der rechtlichen
zuständigkeit ein echt gutes miteinander
und guter austausch und da liegt dann
auch eine stärke drin weil das was in
den ländern auch in den krisenstäben und
in den strukturen dann gegenüber den
kommunen entsteht das kann wenn wir
gemeinsam agieren und das tun wir in
aller regel das kann dann eben auch
stärke bringen so und dass so eine
entscheidung und so eine aussage wie die
am sonntag jetzt mal ein zwei tage
braucht in einem föderalen miteinander
um sich abschließend zu sortieren gehört
dann vielleicht auch dazu aber
entscheidend ist doch dass am ende im
ergebnis dahin kommen wo wir unter
bestand übrigens im ergebnis bei den
gesundheitsministern auch kein zweifel
hin müssen
das ist doch dann auch gut und so club
besuchen will ich einfach nur sagen das
eine ist die dinge zu untersagen das
andere ist aber vielleicht auch noch mal
wieder den bürgern zu sagen
stellt euch einfach die frage muss in
den nächsten drei monaten unbedingt ein
club besuch sein
ich finde die frage kann man ja auch mal
umdrehen muss man immer warten bis etwas
verboten ist
oder kann man auch selbst für sich die
frage sagen zum schutz von anderen
verzichte ich vielleicht mal das eine
oder andere
herr könig und jetzt hier von n tv eine
frage an die frau bundeskanzlerin
vielleicht es geht bei auch nochmals
telefonat mit den eu partnern
sie haben die europäische solidarität
auch angesprochen in italien zeigt sich
zeichnet sich ja gerade ab dass die
kapazitäten endlich sind gibt es auch
überlegen eventuell personal
medizinisches zu verschicken auszuleihen
vielleicht patienten zu übernehmen wenn
sich die lage noch verschlimmern sollte
ich sag mal medizinisches personal
einfach so von einem land ins andere mit
sprachbarrieren und so weiter zu machen
das ist ja sowieso nicht ganz so einfach
aber und außerdem ist natürlich italien
nicht das einzige land das in einer
stresssituation ist aber ich kann ihnen
sagen wir werden mit unseren
italienischen kollegen sprechen ich
werde auch in den nächsten tagen mit
ministerpräsident konnte nochmal reden
was wir tun und verantworten können
werden wir tun
ob bundeskanzlerin sie haben gesagt das
gehe jetzt darum das ist wirtschaftlich
erleben also habe ich sie verstanden
einigermaßen aufrechterhalten zu können
das klingt jetzt nicht danach nach einer
krise die man mit ein bisschen
kurzarbeitergeld für ein paar tage
wieder in den griff bekommt womit
rechnen sie da konkret was die
konjunktur angeht und über die cdu über
den parteitag sind sie so ein bisschen
schnell hinweggegangen auch um
vielleicht den frage an entspannte er
gerade gesagt hat man muss nicht warten
bis etwas verboten ist müssen nicht
gerade die cdu dort mit gutem beispiel
vorangehen es zwei wochen nach ostern
und die veranstaltung frühzeitig absagen
um dort auch ein zeichen zu setzen
mit dem cdu-parteitag beschäftigt was
man sagen will man sich auch wirtschaft
wir können die wirtschaftlichen folgen
noch nicht absehen und das hängt ja auch
damit zusammen dass wir nicht wissen ist
es jetzt einmal den tb abgesagt und eine
absage reihe von zwei monaten oder ist
eine von vier oder es ist eine von sechs
monaten deshalb kann ich das nicht jetzt
schon die folgen abschätzen dass es doch
ganz klar wir müssen
das beobachten und müssen schauen wie
sich die dinge entwickeln und wir sehen
schon betroffenheiten wenn sie sich
einfach mal hotelauslastung angucken
oder stornierungen von urlaubsreisen
oder ähnlichem aber wir können auch noch
nicht sagen geht das jetzt über die
osterzeit hinweg und was bedeutet das
für den sommer also müssen wir schon ein
stück weit auch die dinge immer wieder
neu bewerten und wir haben jetzt ja
gerade hat den sparren gesagt berlin hat
bis ostern zum beispiel bestimmte
absagen gemacht das ist jetzt ein
zeitraum der wird jetzt an vielen
stellen sicherlich gemacht werden damit
man nicht jeden tag neu die dinge machen
muss aber man kann jetzt auch nicht
gleich das juli alles schon voraussagen
und insofern weiß ich noch nicht und
kann ich auch nicht wissen wie die
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen sind aber
wir werden reagieren und
kurzarbeitergeld ist nicht eine sache
für zwei tage sondern kurzarbeitergeld
es etwas was sie über monate gilt wir
haben das kurzarbeitergeld die
verordnungsermächtigungen jetzt bis zwei
ende 2021 auf den weg ort und die
gültigkeit also dass man es anwenden
kann das ende des jahres 2020
das heißt also wir haben jetzt nicht für
14 tage unsere regelungen getroffen
sondern für eine längere zeit
das wird auch bei denen die militärs
maßnahmen am freitag zu sein
ich habe den eindruck aus vielen
gesprächen dass sich alle der hohen
verantwortung und vorbildfunktion
bewusst sind auch rund um den cdu
parteitag dass deswegen ausdrücklich ja
auch alle sagen dass natürlich jeder
option jenseits des es findet statt
eine ist dass man aber eben auch sagt
man schaut was uns rechtlich
organisatorisch überhaupt möglich ist
vielleicht anders damit umzugehen als es
sind ja nicht nur 1001 sie wollen ja im
zweifel auch was davon mitbekommen
und andere auch da damit umzugehen und
ich habe den eindruck dass das alle mit
der nötigen ernsthaftigkeit in den
nötigen verantwortungsbewusstsein dafür
dass das natürlich auch ein vorbild oder
symbolcharakter hat da herangehen glaube
das ganze aus china derzeit nach italien
wird der tatsächlich geschichte
schutzmasken wichtige medizinische
unterlagen und sogar legitim
als ärztin also schließe nicht aus dass
das auch aus deutschland oder andere
europäische länder unmöglich ist in den
nächsten wochen und monate es ist
wirklich so dass die italienische lösung
ist jetzt schon überfordert ist und
gerade in den wichtigen städte wie zum
beispiel mailand und das wäre etwas wie
konkrete maßnahmen und kirche sowie
laden schon mal die auch eine aufwändige
meinung ja wie ich habe ja ich kann das
jetzt nur sagen was ich eben schon
gesagt habe ich werde mit dem
italienischen premierminister noch mal
sprechen hier entspannung von dem
gesundheitsminister im gespräch und ich
habe eben schon gesagt es lässt sich
etwa kalt wenn in italien eine solche
situation ist und wir werden überlegen
was wir tun können um zu helfen wissen
dass auch unser gesundheitssystem ja
nicht jetzt vor keiner herausforderung
steht das ist ja nicht so dass ein land
vielleicht etwas hat wie ein erdbeben
und ein anderes land hat gar nicht
sondern wir sind ja alle in einer
gewissen weise
in einer stresssituation und trotzdem
sind wir uns freundschaftlich verbunden
und so wird man handeln wie man unter
freunden handelt es geht frau
bundeskanzlerin und herr minister ihr
politisches verhältnis miteinander galt
ja in den letzten jahren jetzt nicht als
ultra harmonisch trotzdem ist es ja
wichtig auch für das vertrauen in der
bevölkerung wenn die situation sich
jetzt möglicherweise auch noch zuspitzt
dass man das gefühl hat dass in zwei da
vorne die miteinander harmonieren
könnten sie mal sagen ob sich ihr
verhältnis in den letzten wochen und
monaten in dieser hinsicht verändert
vielleicht sogar verbessert hat eine
frage noch ein professor wähler könnten
sie etwas sagen zu den jüngsten
entwicklungen in china wo er eine also
abnahme der neuinfektionen stattfindet
ist es ein trend der irgend etwas
aussagt was auch uns hoffnung machen
kann also aus der tatsache dass wir
vielleicht in manchen politischen fragen
unterschiedliche einschätzungen haben
was in einer volkspartei perse vorkommen
muss zu schließen dass wenn ich gut
zusammenarbeiten könnten finde ich
relativ kühl und meinem wesen fremd wir
arbeiten im kabinett ist immer super
zusammen und jetzt natürlich noch sehr
viel intensiver und ich habe es gestern
schon eine fraktion gesagt ich finde das
ist jens spahn einen tollen job macht
gerade in einer schwierigen situation
wenn ich mir das als regierungschefin
alles erlauben darf es jetzt immer so an
als wenn man irgendwie bewertungen
vorgibt aber ich habe da volles
vertrauen und wir haben gute schnelle
gespräche super austausch und insofern
da kann sich jeder drauf verlassen kann
nur kurz ergänzen mein eindruck mein
leben meine erfahrung wäre das unser
persönliches verhältnis schon immer
besser war als die meisten von ihnen
manchmal geschrieben
zu der frage das ist eine sehr wichtige
frage noch mal die grundvoraussetzung
wir reden von einem pandemischen virus
60 bis 70 prozent der menschen werden
damit infiziert natürlich wird es auch
so sein dass in china sich wieder
ausbreiten wird es gibt gar keinen grund
das zu bezweifeln
die idee und das war natürlich eine
richtige drastische maßnahme dass man in
johann eine ganze stadt abgeriegelt
hatte ist ja eine sehr drastische
maßnahmen und warum das getan wurde das
glaube ich versteht inzwischen auch
jeder weil eben sehr viele menschen
schwer krank werden die mit der
krankheit infiziert werden mit dem virus
aber wenn man dann natürlich dieses in
diesen sogenannten locker und diese
absperrungen dann wieder aufhebt dann
ist dass wir uns natürlich nicht aus der
welt verschwunden sondern
selbstverständlich wird auch in china
ist in zukunft wieder zunahme von fällen
geben
das sind verschiedene wellen aber kein
mensch weiß wann das sein wird und wie
viel das sein wird
und natürlich auch noch einmal darum
dieser aspekt mit dem abriegeln oder der
der vorstellung dass man etwas aus einem
land halten kann das ist naiv ja sagen
wir selbst wenn man das schafft eine
gewisse zeit das virus wird dann
irgendwann natürlich trotzdem in dieses
land kommen also es geht darum alles zu
verlangsamen und der pfütze sorge zu
tragen dass es möglichst an vielen nicht
an vielen stellen gleichzeitig auftritt
sondern dass man nicht gegenseitig
unterstützen kann dass man gerade die
kapazitäten im gesundheitswesen nutzen
kann um sich zu unterstützen und die
patienten zu versorgen
und nochmal der aspekt es wird ja auch
irgendwann eine impfstoff geben das
dauert aber noch eine weile
und ja also vor 2021 ist das
unrealistisch dann kann man natürlich
auch impfen und es wirkt sich natürlich
auch zunehmend eine immunität in der
bevölkerung ausbilden denn da er mehr
als 80 prozent der menschen die
infiziert wendung milde symptome haben
haben sie auch eine gewisse mobilität
das heißt also das ganze weiter gehende
die die art und weise wie es das virus
von mir verbreiten wird ob es eine
saisonalität ist das werden wir alles
sehen und wir tun alles um diese ganzen
effekte abzumildern
aber dass china das virus nun doch
wieder hin kommt das ist aus
wissenschaftlicher sicht sicher wir
haben 12 45 war eine gute nachricht gut
zwei drittel abgearbeitet ein drittel
haben wir nicht geschafft das tut mir
leid die letzte frage hat deswegen bevor
ich eine letzte frage ob bundeskanzlerin
katja pressekonferenz ein bisschen fühlt
man sich erinnert an die historische
pressekonferenzen nach dem motto
unterwegs von draghi oder auch ihre ihr
presseauftritt seien derzeit in der
finanzkrise die guthaben sicher wenn sie
diese pressekonferenz nehmen angesichts
der bedrohung wie würden sie das
einordnen
wir sind wie herr professor dealer
gesagt hat und wie ich also wie es mir
auch logisch erscheint und ich sowieso
auf seinen rat hörer am anfang einer
entwicklung die wir noch nicht genau
voraussehen können und deshalb wird es
noch viele presse begegnungen wir jetzt
mal nächsten besuch in der
bundespressekonferenz ankündigte wir
werden noch viel mit der frage die über
die wir heute gesprochen haben zu tun
haben und das ist eine pressekonferenz
aus meiner sicht die sozusagen den blick
weitet für die herausforderung vor der
wir stehen aber wo wir noch nicht an
allen stellen die lösungen anbieten
können so und die botschaft sollte sein
wir werden das notwendige tun als land
und das auch noch im europäischen
verbund ich fand das sehr sehr wichtig
wäre mir ein anderes thema wo wir jetzt
auch gerade
flüchtlinge sprechen und die europäische
union damit ihren institutionen und
ihren mitgliedstaaten soll einfach in
solchen großen herausforderungen
sichtbar sein und ich glaube auch das
können wir das niemals ideal aber was
die gesundheitsminister sich schon weil
zum beispiel schon zweimal getroffen
haben zeigt auch dass wir das auch als
eine europäische herausforderung
begreifen
vielen dank frau bundeskanzlerin dank an
minister vielen dank herr wieland sie
schon nicht mehr zu sehen ich danke
ihnen und bis zum nächsten mal